il a toujours eu l'équipe de france dans
sa tête
donc quand il n'est pas forcément aidé
par contre il a eu des petits tracas
aujourd'hui il n'existe plus ce truc là
parce que je veux dire c'est que
on a juste besoin de voir aujourd'hui le
footballeur d'ailleurs ce que peu à car
karim apporter à cette équipe
j'étais déçu que karim ne fasse pas
partie de l'équipe de france lors de
l'euro j'espère que karim pourra aller à
la coupe du monde
c'est mon souhait parce que c'est un
joueur fantastique et j'aime voir les
grands joueurs dans les grandes
compétitions
j'espère que karim pourra aller à la
coupe du monde dames le maillot bleu
assure qu'il aime l'équipe de france et
n'a envie de jouer pour son pays
je veux qu'il fasse froid de plus il
marque des buts laetitia au real madrid
tu prends pas en équipe de france quand
je marche en angleterre dès que ça parle
football on me demande pourquoi tu as un
benzema est en sélection je vais vous
poser la question à la mauvaise personne
autre mode et faut demander à
l'entraîneur et il faut respecter ses
choix
c'est un cas mondiale dont des
programmes parlés de seulement de la
ligue 1 même de la ligue a ou c mondiale
il ya des joueurs qui sont partis
l'équipe de france et percevant de
demandes de retour même s'ils ont mis
des bus après dans leur club mais c'est
karim benzema
donc voilà où le problème